Loop Paradox what is that yeah so you
you don't want to have loops in space
and time in which you can't have cause
and effect be logically consistent right
so we're all used to things in the past
affecting things in the future but if
time loops around then the future
actually can affect the past so the
danger in a theory and one of the
Diagnostics we use to see if a theory is
healthy is to make sure it doesn't have
any of these closed Tim likee Curves in
which cause and effect would be muddled
up by the structure of SpaceTime this is
a philosophical bias you are
implementing on the universe itself it's
a little bit more than philosophical
because you want the unfolding of events
to be internally
[Music]
consistent